[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john smoltz joining us john part of the
fox sports one broadcast uh red sox
raise for game one and game two that
starts tomorrow night followed by mlb
network's exclusive broadcast of game
three on sunday at four eastern we were
just talking about stadiums john if i
said best stadium to pitch in
what would you say
uh today best stadium i mean the old
astro stadium just doesn't get any
better than that i mean
throw fastballs 95 see if they could hit
it out of the stadium there's not many
of those anymore unless wrigley's
blowing in uh so i would say if the
wind's blowing in wrigley but in the
stadiums today i mean dodger stadium's
pretty fair you know i'm not
this marine layer thing that's been
talked about whether it's gone or there
the ball travels doesn't travel at night
travels during the day
but dodger stadium is a pretty fair
place to
to pitch when uh the thick marine error
is uh at night what's the worst stadium
to pitch in
oh my goodness there's more of those
than there's ever been
it's like
you know camden yards is a great place
to hit a small american ballpark in
cincinnati
uh i call it small american ball park
because it's very tiny
the central seems to be one of the worst
places to pitch when it comes to the
teams and of course colorado is not fun
at all when when you think about
a visitor in colorado great place to
watch a game not a great place to pitch
if you're a pitcher what about san
francisco that feels like it there's
parts of it that's a good pitchers ball
park
yeah the new stadium is fantastic as far
as the weather you know the weather at
old candlestick could have been you
start at 70 and you finish at 40. it
seemed like when the layer would come in
over that i don't know who thought
putting a stadium right behind that rock
was
was a good idea but i wasn't i'm a fan
of the new uh stadium in san francisco
very fair
if you hit it down the lines you can go
so they've uh
they've maximized what i thought was the
impossible
in the fact that they hit so many home
runs i didn't think that was part of i
mean
this has been the most amazing year
of storylines of predictions that you
never thought would happen they're
leading the case for the most
unpredictable uh success story how does
it happen
i you know what i i'd like to say this
is not a formula for success long term
year to year they have made every right
decision they've had every right player
in the right spot give their
organization managerial all their
strategy i don't know that that can
continue year to year you can't keep
plugging in
those kind of things but i will say this
they're older guys that which i'm a fan
of because you know analytics says
you're old so you can't play at 30.
they've had a little chip on their
shoulder they've been healthy and they
have delivered big time so that has been
a
kind of like a
an organization filled with players that
you see there longer than most and it's
paying off they won a few championships
this year i'll be the first to tell you
i got on you know beginning of the year
no chance they weren't even in the
discussion
and that's why i said it's the most
remarkable year i can ever remember from
a team that maybe should have won 75 to
80 games
106 or seven that that to me is a great
credit to their organization are you all
on board with the uh playoff format the
one game playoffs
no no i never have been i can say that
consistently i understand
why it was put in place ironically it
was probably put in place because of the
1993
uh giants and braves race to the pennant
and we won it on the last day and the
giants had 103 wins and didn't make the
playoffs there comes the one game
playoff to try to secure a team like
that situation now fast forward this
year
if both these teams end up not moving on
you're gonna see a change i believe in
the playoff format because you it's hard
to imagine that you would have a 105 win
team which easily could lose to the st
louis cardinals not move on and our
whole season is based on the you know
most wins
i think if anything dan i would tweak if
they don't want to make a wholesale
change i would tweak
a scenario where you have tonight the
cardinals should have to beat the
dodgers twice
right i mean the dodgers won a hundred
and some games the cardinals did a great
job down the stretch
but the team with the best record in the
wild card should at least
have an advantage to where they they
only have to win once and the second
team has to win twice
personally i'd like to see playoffs
always have a two out of three no matter
what scenario you set out it needs to be
a series you need to have a fighting
chance and i think we need to start
rewarding the teams who have the best
record give them a buy so that when they
play a team that's already played two
out of three there's your incentive for
the team that's won all those games
otherwise you know it is a little bit
more random
let me look at last night's game aaron
boone takes out garrett cole
and i don't know if you run the risk of
embarrassing your pitcher your 300
million dollar pitcher
in a situation like that
i mean i applaud aaron boone for doing
it because i think it was the right call
but
man that's difficult for a guy who's
probably got his job on the line
and you're going out there and taking
the ball from your your starting pitcher
what did you think of that move at the
time
well
let's just say eric cole the last three
outings haven't been garrett cole and i
know he had the hamstring injury and
there's probably something to do with
that because he when garrett cole
doesn't look like you're cole
you throw everything out the window
because it's that one game scenario that
you needed a great performance and it
just didn't look like he was on his top
of his game you don't have the time and
luxury as a manager
to factor in all that so i thought it
was a really good move to just at least
give him and it worked out because he
got out of an impossible situation
holmes did a great job so those one game
playoffs are another reason why i don't
like it they're manager killers uh you
basically don't have the luxury of a lot
of things because the panic and stress
on that game doesn't leave you any room
for error
and the yankees aren't good enough to
hate anymore
right one world series in 17 years
you that's a good point because you know
the stress on the dodgers and the
yankees was the highest it's ever been
the dodgers won the world series last
year they had one in 30 some years those
are two iconic organizations there's so
much pressure on the yankees right now
and certainly that organization for what
they built but you're right this year
just was a roller coaster year they've
been through everything their offense
was hot and cold and i think that's not
a good formula for a deep run i mean
they're certainly going to be right back
there next year and could be the
favorites who knows what the off season
brings but this year was the streakiest
most unpredictable baseball season i've
ever seen you're talking about teams
losing records on the road and then
you're talking about home teams uh teams
that have won
games over 10 in a row multiple times so
it's a crazy year it's one of those that
i think a lot of people were waiting to
see after the
covet year of the short season how it
was going to play out he's john smoltz
the hall of famer and he'll be part of
fox sports one's broadcast red sox at
the rays game one
and uh also game two that starts
tomorrow night um i look at the the
dodgers situation where you've been
great all year long but then you run
into
one of the hottest teams that we've seen
in recent memory
how do you how do you handicap this game
with these two
well the beautiful thing for both teams
they have the picture they want on the
mound sometimes you get into these games
you don't have the luxury the dodgers
were almost forced to play that it would
have been interesting to see how the
dodgers played the one game playoff to
determine the division
championship had they been in that spot
so i think there's some relief in that
regard where they can put everything
towards this one game uh but it's a high
stress and kind of flip of the coin adam
wainwright the veteran of course my
former teammate both pitchers know how
to pitch in big moments so that won't be
unnerving uh it's going to come down to
who can kind of like last night's game
who can score first and create pressure
on the manager
i couldn't help but notice and maybe
there's nothing to it when kershaw was
pulled from his last start he kept the
ball
he walked off the mound with the ball
i know he doesn't need tommy john
surgery he's been through an awful lot
do you think there was anything to that
that kershaw kept the ball when he
walked off the field
you know until you mention it probably
wouldn't have thought twice about it but
having the kind of career he's had and
where he's at in his career i know this
year there was a lot of talk possibly of
could he be headed for tommy john you
know you're talking about kershaw and
burlander two i consider
surefire hall of famers that have some
life left in their game and
probably don't need anything more to get
there but i know verlander coming back
from tommy john as an older guy he wants
to win a lot more games and i would
think kershaw is similar but winning the
world series
maybe takes a lot less stress off of him
from having to prove to people so many
much more but i it's a great question i
didn't even think about it because you
don't ever take a ball
off the mound as uh the season ends yeah
you don't like you have to hand it to
the manager when it comes out that's
that's part of the uh the ceremony there
yeah
yeah it's an interesting interesting uh
thing to follow us i'm sure the dodgers
are uh monitoring that very closely yeah
and he's gonna miss the postseason
because he's got that forearm elbow
injury like it i i don't know exactly
what that is it more elbow than forearm
john
you know
typically in in a picture the opposites
work the top of the the
the arm is going to be you're concerning
here if it's the bottom side you're not
as concerned but forearms never a great
issue to have unless it truly is um
not connected
to the elbow which is hard to imagine
that they wouldn't a lot of forearm
injuries usually turn into what people
thought talk about as a precursor to
tommy john but not necessarily in his
case it could be something different
before you go introduce america again
to the tampa bay rays
it's i just don't get it like i i really
am in awe of what they've been able to
do uh i will spend all day thursday
getting
introduced to the tampa bay rays because
i'll be doing a deep dive into their
rotation which is almost brand new uh
their bullpen is as interchangeable
parts their offense seems to just slug
wander franco is the real deal because
when everyone was wanting him up in the
beginning of the year and they delayed
his clock for obvious reasons but
they're going to start two rookies
that you rarely see from a team that
almost won the world series
that left two of their stud starters to
go somewhere else
i i the rays are are an amazing
organization that uh
quite frankly a lot of people stop
trying to figure out and they just go
with it and when they push a button you
know it might be the right button of
course last year the button that was
pushed in game six filled their formula
of while they went about their business
but
a lot of people you know would wonder
what would have happened if they left in
blake snell they don't even think about
it they turn the page because they're on
a quest to prove everybody wrong
always great to catch up with you john
have fun with the red sox and the raise
thank you bud
looking forward to it thanks that's john
smolt's hall of famer mlb network
analyst